♪♪♪
>> MR. ABBETON.
MR. EBERLE.
CHOOSE YOUR WEAPONS.
>> OH, KIND SIRS.
MY AFFECTIONS ARE NOT WORTH THIS
QUARREL.
WHATEVER INJURY YOU ANY MIGHT
INCUR CANNOT COMPETE WITH THE
WOUND YOU INFLICT UPON MY HEART.
>> LISTEN TO HER GENTLEMAN.
NO WOMAN IS WORTH LOSING LIFE
AND LIMB OVER.
>> THIS MAN HAS LAID CLAIM TO
WHAT IS RIGHTFULLY MINE.
AND I WILL HAVE SATISFACTION.
>> I WILL NOT REST UNTIL HIS
BLOOD IS SPILLED UPON THIS VERY
CROWN.
>> I CANNOT BEAR TO SEE EITHER
OF YOU SUFFER EVEN THE SLIGHTEST
OF WOUNDS.
>> THEN I SUGGEST YOU LOOK AWAY.
>> DO AS HE SAYS, MY LADY.
>> YOU AGREED UPON THE TERMS.
TEN PACES AND THEN TURN AND
FIRE.
MR. ABBETON.
>> READY.
>> MR. EBERLE.
>> BAM!
>> OH, ARE YOU OKAY?
>> OH, MY GOD, SORRY.
>> I THINK HE GOT A LITTLE BIT
SHOT.
>> THE ONLY PAIN I FEEL IS
SEEING THE TWO MEN I ADORE AT
ODDS.
>> WELL, YOU'RE DEFINITELY
BLEEDING.
>> IT'S NOTHING COMPARED TO
THEIR SUFFERING.
>> GENTLEMEN, I THINK WE SHOULD
GO OVER THE RULES BEGIN.
>> YES.
BECAUSE HE WENT EARLY, RIGHT?
SO, JUST TO BE CLEAR, YOU WILL
WALK TEN PACES AND THEN TURN AND
SHOOT.
UNDERSTOOD?
>> AND WHAT DO I DO?
>> WELL, THE SAME THING.
>> AS BEFORE?
OKAY.
BANG!
>> 'TIS BUT A PIN PRICK.
THE ONLY PAIN IS LOVING A WOMAN
THAT ANOTHER MAN LOVES.
>> I'M SORRY, MY LADY.
I'M NOT VERY GOOD AT THIS GAME.
>> DO NOT GIVE ME A SECOND
THOUGHT.
I BESEECH YOU, SIR.
THINK ONLY OF YOURSELF.
>> OKAY, PERHAPS WE SHOULD
ABANDON THE GUNS AND TAKE OFF
OUR CLOTHES AND FIGHT.
>> OUR CLOTHES.
WHY ARE YOU INVOLVED?
>> WELL, I'M MAD TOO.
THIS IS TAKING UP MY WHOLE DAMN
DAY.
>> LET'S TRY ONE MORE TIME.
>> I'M JUST GOING TO MOVE YOU
HERE RIGHT IN FRONT OF HER.
>> SO, THAT WAY I CAN SEE.
>> GENTLEMEN, I'M GOING TO WALK
YOU THROUGH THIS.
DO EXACTLY AS I SAY.
TAKE ONE STEP --
>> ONE STEP?
I THOUGHT WE WERE GOING TO TAKE
TEN.
>> ARE WE AT TEN ALREADY?
BANG.
>> NO, I HAVEN'T GOTTEN TO GO
BANG ONCE!
BANG.
>> CURRENTLY THERE ARE TWO
BULLETS AND THEY ARE BOUNCING
AROUND THE COURTYARD.
I'M SURE I CAN JUST PEEK OUT TO
SEE WHAT'S HANNING.
HAPPENING.
>> OH, MY LORD.
I HATE THIS DAY.
>> THE TWO OF YOU SHOULD BE
ASHAMED!
HAND ME THAT PISTOL.
>> DO BE CAREFUL.
>> WHAT?
OH!
>> OH, MY GOD.
GIVE THAT BACK.
>> WHY DID YOU DO THAT?
>> I'M SORRY, I WAS TRYING
SOMETHING.
>> THIS ENDS NOW!
>> MY LADY, YOUR LEGS!
>> MR. EBERLE.
MR. ABBETON.
I HAVE SOMETHING TO SAY AND I
WILL BE HEARD!
YOU HAVE SUFFERED ENOUGH.
>> SHE'S RIGHT.
DO YOU FORGIVE ME?
>> I DO.
>> NOW GIVE ME THOSE WEAPONS AND
LET THE HEALING BEGIN.
>> OH!
>> YEP, THAT'S A HAIR TRIGGER
RIGHT THERE.